the virtual reality realm has progressed
from a hypothetical sci-fi fantasy to a
competitive marketable reality really
quickly in fact in the last few weeks a
bunch of new companies have joined the
VR race so I'm here to give you the gist
on some of the biggest offerings first
up let's talk about the oculus rift the
oculus rift burst onto the scene via
kickstarter in 2012 we left it up
because it was essentially the first of
its caliber in VR and it was coming from
an independent developer you know before
Facebook bought it the proposed consumer
version which is currently in
development will have integrated audio
and better head and positional tracking
and the presently available developer
kit models on top of that the device
will feature a 1080p low persistence of
vision o LED display as well as 7-inch
stereoscopic displays and 24-bit color
depth the most commonly mentioned issues
the rift is combating are the weight of
the device as well as ensuring
affordability and improved performance
then there's project Morpheus which is
your playstation 4 option this one is
going to launch early next year and
features nine tracking LEDs which work
to make positional tracking as accurate
as possible it has a 5.7 inch screen and
support a 100 degree field of view the
latest model features a 1920 x 1080 oh
LED display and a massive 120 Hertz
refresh rate sony have also touted their
strapless sleek design and emphasis on
comfort they've shifted most of the way
to the top of the head distancing
themselves from the more uncomfortable
traditional goggle style headset
basically this is the one you'll be
picking up for your ps4 vr needs next up
we've got razor whose VR headset is
backed by Ubisoft and will only run you
200 bucks the first of the lot to drop a
price razors offering is open source and
has virtual reality goggles facturers
centex joining razor at the hell
as with all things VR there is a dev kit
and a consumer kit the first of which is
now available from raises website the
headset comes with a full HD oh LED
display which offers higher contrast
with low latency thanks to foster pixel
switching they also reckon it's going to
be comfy which is always a plus with
these things not to be left out AMD have
also plunged into virtual reality with
their entry called liquid VR liquid VR
is using AMD's GPU software and hardware
systems in the hopes to reduce latency
to less than 10 milliseconds ideally
that'll keep you immersed throughout the
experience and should also stop you
getting motion sick which happens when
the environment feels too artificial and
your brain can't adapt quickly enough
liquid via also hopes to work with other
VR devices that are on the market they
also want to have a plug-and-play sort
of system with their AMD Radeon graphics
cards to keep the experience seamless
although there's a lot going on in the
virtual reality space right now Alvin
HTC vive headset seems to be getting
most of the attention and for good
reason the developer edition uses to
1200 x 1080 displays which refresh at 90
frames per second this promises to
eliminate the jitter that can plague VR
devices and unlike other offerings with
vive you can physically walk around a
virtual environment the headset which is
complete with gyro sensor accelerometer
and laser position sensor is coupled
with steam VR base stations which track
your physical location in spaces up to
15 square feet val have also introduced
a room scale tracking system called
lighthouse which will enable high speed
pinpoint tracking for any number of
targets although they plan to make this
freely available to hardware
manufacturers vive is also partnered
with HBO Lionsgate and Google and with a
name like valve behind it big things are
expected from the headset particularly
given that valve is shooting for
seamless integration with steam VR
titles which are growing by the day and
currently include games like tf2 Proteus
and portal currently the main concern
will be how val
an HTC will keep the price down with all
these technologies and peripherals not
to mention the requirement of a really
beefy PC to run the whole thing at it's
optimized resolution let me know down in
the comments which VR headset you reckon
is the one to watch I'll catch again
next week